Russia says that its troops have killed
more than 70 fighters who staged an
attack in the belgarde region which
borders Ukraine the local headquarters
of Russia's Security Service the FSB is
said to have been targeted
evacuated residents have been warned not
to return home until they're told it's
safe now it's the most significant
incursion into Russia since Moscow
invaded Ukraine 15 months ago
two groups call the liberty of Russia
Legion and the Russian volunteer Corps
say they're behind the Belgard attack
Jonah Hull has more
a cross-border raid apparently carried
out by ethnic Russians on Russian
territory there is much about these
images that doesn't seem to fit yet
armed men from two groups called the
Russia volunteer Corps and the liberty
of Russia Legion claimed to have
captured several Towns close to the
Ukrainian border
forward units they reported on Twitter
had entered the town of grevoron home to
a Russian military base where they used
drones to attack the local headquarters
of Russia's Security Service the FSB
these pictures cannot be independently
verified video on social media purports
to show two men making their escape in a
captured armored vehicle
the fighters describe themselves as
Russian citizens opposed to the Kremlin
they can be seen here wearing Ukrainian
Insignia in a video statement posted on
social media
the statement rails against dictatorship
and official corruption in Russia in
what some observers see as a possible
Prelude to Ukraine's long-anticipated
counter-offensive I think there's three
aims of an action like we've seen in
Belgrade firstly it's to tie down to fix
as many Russian forces in the area as
possible so that they can't man areas
where Ukraine may actually attack
secondly it's to show to Russians across
their media that actually the war has
come to Russia uh on their territory in
a small way and finally to embarrass
Putin the attacks sparked the evacuation
of Russian citizens from the area as the
authorities said a counter-terrorism
operation was underway
these images were later released by the
defense Ministry Russia's retaliation it
said claiming to have killed dozens of
Fighters residents later said they'd
never seen anything like it first guns
then mortars machine guns said this man
it was full-on fighting
bloodstains were Testament to casualties
although the specifics are unclear
speaking to reporters by phone the
Kremlin spokesman said the attackers
were Ukrainian
they are Ukrainian militants from
Ukraine there are many ethnic Russians
living in Ukraine but they are Ukrainian
militants anyway in response Ukraine
said it had quote nothing to do with it
Jonah Hull Al Jazeera
Moscow Bay's journalist Julia
chapovalova has the latest on what the
Kremlin is saying about the attack
the ministry of Defense blamed kiev for
that hikes in their latest statements
they said after Kiev suffered a defeat
in our Thomas that's the Russian name of
bahmoud several days ago they've
switched to carrying out terrorist
attacks against the civilian population
of Russia it began on Monday and after
heavier shelling a unit of a Ukrainian a
nationalist invaded a Russian territory
that's according to the Russian defense
Ministry and as we understand as a
result of the shelling two Russian
soldiers were killed of four more
injured their attacks continued on
Tuesday the governor of the Belgard
region said that on Tuesday Morning the
Ukrainian military fired at residential
buildings with multiple launch rocket
systems and used drones these so-called
Liberty of Russia Legion has claimed
responsibility for that tax they are
considered a terrorist and extremist
organization here in Russia and they are
said to be a part of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces consisting allegedly of ethnic
Russian volunteers they say their goal
is to free Russia and change its
political system and according to
kremlin's spokesperson Dmitry biskov
Russia's special military operation in
Ukraine is designed to prevent cases
like that one from happening in the
future and speaking about ethnic
Russians in the group that attacks the
Belgard region he said that all of them
are Ukrainian militants